[Música]
Bienvenidos a Expreso de oriente soy
Marina sardinha y les doy la bienvenida
a esta edición especial dedicada a las
elecciones de Turquía comenzamos Y es
que Turquía va a segunda vuelta después
de una jornada electoral histórica con
un ligerísimo margen el actual
mandatario reyecta y perdón lideró los
comicios con tan solo el 49% de los
votos frente a su rival el opositor que
mal quilice con el 45% ninguno de los
dos principales candidatos lograron la
mayoría absoluta necesaria por lo tanto
que tendrán que enfrentarse de nuevo el
próximo 28 de mayo recordemos que 64
millones de turcos estaban llamados a
las urnas para elegir al jefe de estado
y 600 diputados del parlamento y la
participación fue de poco más del 88%
y para analizar los resultados de estos
comitios históricos y reñidos que han
tenido en vilo toda la noche a Turquía
pero también el panorama que se viene
por delante hablamos con aribel
Contreras Suárez ella es analista de
asuntos globales Gracias por estar en
France 24 aribel lo primero una victoria
insuficiente de rieta y perdón que
lideró la primera vuelta con un margen
estrechísimo frente a su rival que mal
quilisdarolu recordemos que llevamos a
unos comicios en plena crisis económica
en Turquía y con una sociedad muy
polarizada Cómo analiza usted estos
resultados
Así es Marina gusto saludarte y gracias
por esta gentil invitación estamos
viendo que a la luz de estos resultados
de esta primera vuelta de elecciones en
Turquía pues esto lo debemos de Traducir
que ni al presidente de Turquía le
alcanzó para evitar la segunda vuelta
pero tampoco a la alianza opositora le
alcanzó y le Fue suficiente para poder
ganar es esto es bien importante porque
una vez que se llegue a esta segunda
vuelta y se tenga un ganador tendrá que
interpretar qué es lo que los turcos
están diciendo porque estarás recibiendo
un país totalmente
polarizado dividido no solamente en
términos electorales sino
geográficamente cuando uno entiende el
voto urbano el voto rural pero también
Marina Cuando vemos un mapa
digamos demográfico donde helado oeste
de Turquía es la zona mucho más
industrializada donde se concentran en
grandes ciudades la población hay una
gran asimetría en el país Así que vaya
retos a los que tendrá que enfrentarse
quien gane pero también esto habla mucho
de que la población ya no quiere más del
erdoganismo también hay ha habido
Durante este conteo de votos acusaciones
de ambos candidatos de juegos sucio Cómo
recibe la oposición estos resultados y
Qué representa en estos momentos
quilicedarol el oponente de erdogan en
la segunda vuelta Cuáles son también sus
posibilidades de ganar en esta segunda
ronda
importante que veamos por qué se va a
decantar el tercer candidato o dan
porque aunque ganó muy poco ese pequeño
margen de cinco por ciento puede marcar
la diferencia para esta Alianza nacional
para que entonces la balanza se incline
por el candidato quemal de no sabemos
finalmente
qué botón accionador político electoral
vaya a apretar el hogar en el sentido de
que serán pues dos semanas álgidas de
mucha atención al interior de Turquía
donde los reflectores Internacionales
estarán puestos ahí porque estas
elecciones impactan no solamente a
Turquía sino pueden abonar a la
estabilidad o inestabilidad de la región
Y por supuesto pues ver y se avanzará
hacia nuevas alianzas con occidente y se
logrará este distanciamiento que se con
respecto al presidente Vladimir Putin
Así que Creo yo que se trazará una ruta
muy distinta con un personaje o con otro
pero también habrá que observar Cómo va
a quedar conformado el parlamento en
estos seiscientos escaños para
visualizar si le permitirán avanzar al
ejecutivo o no en su agenda política
para los próximos años Marina Maribel y
gane o no el actual mandatario en la
segunda vuelta parece que ni la crisis
financiera ni los terremotos que dejaron
más de 50.000 muertos han sido un golpe
a la popularidad Dean Cómo ha marcado a
la sociedad turca estos 20 años de poder
de este mandatario islamista
Así es Marina lo destacas y lo destacas
muy bien
pensaríamos que estas dos décadas donde
se había pulverizado la figura del
presidente Turco pero también se ha
fragmentado la la sociedad ante una
economía afectada primero por la
pandemia y después por la guerra en
Ucrania con una inflación por arriba de
50% con una Lira turca pulverizada con
unas tasas de interés altísimas y un
poder adquisitivo cada vez más
adelgazado pensábamos que entonces le
iban a cobrar factura en esta jornada
electoral pero vemos entonces que hay
todavía grandes alas conservadoras que
le siguen apostando a su plan de
gobierno que siguen creyendo que su
gobierno totalitario antidemocrático es
el rumbo que debe de seguir teniendo
Turquía preocupante pero real y entonces
pues si hay continuidad en su gobierno
esto hablará mucho de que quienes
salieron a votar en las calles son
personas que creen que eso es lo
correcto puesto que las generaciones
nuevas con él nacieron y no han visto
otra cosa sin embargo las generaciones
pues ya de gente más grande Pues sí
estaría apostando creo yo a un cambio
radical en el caso que la segunda vuelta
veamos a que mal como triunfador Pues
tendrá muchos retos para poder tener
gobernabilidad entre este país que va a
recibir en ceniza
si precisamente también quería hablar de
Cuál ha sido el papel de los jóvenes que
por primera vez votan y que no han
conocido otro gobierno más allá que el
de erdogan si esto también puede variar
en la segunda vuelta y hacer que se
ingiere La balanza de un lado a otro
sin duda alguna Marina estaremos viendo
que dentro de estos más de sesenta y
cuatro millones de habitantes que
pertenecen a la base electoral Pues
porque la población es de más de 80
millones de turcos pues eh el sector de
los jóvenes
promete bastante en cuanto a que también
están muy divididos hay quienes como tú
bien destacas no conocen otra opción y
creen que esto es lo correcto y es el
único rumbo que Turquía puede detener
pero también hay jóvenes que están en
contacto con redes sociales que han
viajado que conocen otras realidades
fuera de Turquía o bien que tienen
familiares que se encuentran en otros
países y que por lo tanto buscarían un
cambio sustancial y estructural en
Turquía para tener un nuevo rumbo sobre
todo no solamente en sus bolsillos sino
sobre todo una nueva cara para Turquía
más democrática con menos corrupción y
sobre todo que haya derechos humanos
y también brevemente Cómo cree que
podría la comunidad internacional
recibir un nuevo mandato de duan también
teniendo en cuenta un poco el papel del
líder Turco por ejemplo en la Guerra de
Ucrania
claro quien estaría más feliz Pues sería
Vladimir Putin en el kremlin aplaudiendo
que una vez más su gran Aliado
incondicional pues va a permanecer en el
poder su gran cómplice en esta supuesta
mediación con Ucrania donde finalmente
hemos visto que a erdogan le encanta
jugar en doble pista sacar beneficios de
su cercanía con el kremling pero también
beneficios por ser miembro de esta
Alianza militar conocida como la otan
donde continuará estrangulando la
membresía de Suecia sin embargo en el
caso de que pues perdiera Pues sería
bastante aplaudido por occidente puesto
que quemal le apuesta mucho a alinearse
hacia Europa y en un futuro trabajar de
manera
sistemática y a través de reformas
estructurales para nuevamente tocar base
para presentar su candidatura para
ingresar a la Unión Europea marina
Ariel Contreras Muchísimas gracias por
este análisis y por estar aquí con
nosotras en France 24
encantada y un gusto como siempre Hasta
pronto y gracias gracias y seguimos con
un recordatorio de la situación
financiera en la que está sumida Turquía
que sin duda ha tenido un gran peso en
el voto de los turcos veamos un panorama
económico al que tendrá que hacer frente
el próximo presidente que será electo el
próximo 28 de mayo puesto que vamos a
una segunda vuelta si bien durante la
primera década del mandato de erdoan se
caracterizó por una buena gestión y un
crecimiento experimentado en los últimos
años esa situación se ha desacelerado
octubre del año pasado la inflación
alcanzó el
85,51% anual si la comparación se hace
con las grandes economías del mundo como
Reino Unido la zona Euro Estados Unidos
o china La Brecha es altísima una
situación que ha causado una fuerte
crisis en el costo de vida de los turcos
además el valor del dólar se ha
multiplicado por 9 en la última década
en Turquía eso significa que la moneda
local turca ha perdido casi el 95% de su
valor en ese lapso de tiempo en términos
más simples en 2013 cada dólar costaba
dos liras turcas hoy en día cuesta
alrededor de 20 liras esto sin duda será
un problema a atajar en los próximos
cinco años dado que Turquía debe
importar la mayoría de los bienes
necesarios para producir
y como decíamos el mandatario reyectai
perdogan logró hacerse con la primera
vuelta frente a su rival el opositor que
mal quilícerolu pero el margen fue
estrechísimo unos dos millones de votos
de diferencia desde Estambul nuestro
corresponsal Albert naya nos contó
previamente que podría pasar con el más
de 5% de los votos del candidato sin
anogan el tercer candidato que se queda
fuera de la segunda vuelta
es la gran pregunta que se hace ahora
mismo toda Turquía que será de los votos
para sin anuar el mismo candidato
presidencial o han ya ha dicho que aún
no se ha decantado por ninguno de los
dos candidatos Y esto es un hecho
bastante importante aquí en Turquía
puesto que normalmente los electores que
votan a un candidato En caso de que este
candidato no pase a una segunda ronda le
harían casos Si él pide el voto para
hiperdogán o para
quemarrollo sí que es verdad que sinan o
han ya hecho una serie de declaraciones
buenas declaraciones hacia el ministro
del interior Suleiman soy Lu ahora mismo
ponerdogan por lo tanto algunos pueden
ver en estas palabras
un digamos una forma de decir que pedirá
futuramente el voto para recetas aún así
aún no se ha pronunciado
llegamos así al final de esta edición
especial de Expreso de oriente Muchas
gracias por acompañarnos sigan con
nuestra programación en France 24.com
[Música]